en l'état actuel c'est qui apparaît
regarde des premières investigations
peuvent être réalisés c'est que nous
avons besoin de témoignages nous avons
en l'occurrence il est certain qu'il ya
pu avoir plusieurs personnes qui
pouvaient être présentes et nous avons
besoin dans de pouvoir recueillir ces
différents témoignages
pour mieux comprendre et mieux analyser
le déroulement et l'enchaînement des
faits qui se sont produits
avant-hier soir à cet égard là je dois
donc par conséquent demander vraiment à
ceux qui ont pu être témoins de venir
auprès des services de police judiciaire
étant précisé j'indique là très
clairement c'est que il y a également
des possibilités si des personnes
craignent pour pour elle même
il y a des possibilités de témoignages
souci que c'est à dire en l'occurrence
en préservant intégralement l'anonymat
des personnes qui pourront ainsi nous
apporter des éléments encore une fois
qu'ils sont essentiels si on veut
pouvoir rapidement mettre hors d'état de
nuire
cette équipe qui est manifestement
extrêmement dangereuse par ailleurs
également ce que je vous indiquais c'est
qu'il ya une mobilisation totale mais
alors absolument totale des services de
justice et de police et de gendarmerie
j'en veux pour preuve encore la réunion
que nous venons à l'instant de terminer
qui avait pour objectif de vérifier
entre les différents services que la
coordination se faisait au mieux et que
en l'occurrence il puisse y avoir
également l'intégralité des moyens qui
sont nécessaires pour élucider ces
affaires qui soit mobiliser concrètement
pour nous permettre d'élucider ces
dossiers